the head of the Met Mark Rowley has said
that he doesn't want his officers taking
the knee or sporting political causes
anymore whilst they're on duty yeah I do
support that I think the police have
become admired in all sorts of
distracting activities and virtue
signaling that that is almost
antithetical to their opinion purpose as
it were which is to solve private
protect the public policing shouldn't be
politicized we've seen the damage that
politicized policing can cause across
the board including books recently in
Northern Ireland where police officers
Junior police officers have thrown on
with the bus by a psni leadership that
was cowed by Sinn fein's demands for the
scalps of these officers so we did check
polish completely out of policing a lot
of includes identity politics includes
all other forms of virtue signaling we
need to get back to basics to use that
Infamous phrase with the police are
simply involved to protect the public
and to solve crime